well my friends it is happening again a
lawyer for former vice president Mike
Pence recently discovered a dozen
classified documents at Mike Pence's
Indiana home these documents have now
been turned over to the FBI for review
now at this early stage in this new
investigation related to classified
documents it's not completely clear what
documents were found at Mike Pence's
house their level of sensitivity or
other details but let's remember that
multiple times former vice president
Mike Penn stated there are no classified
documents in my possession there are no
classified documents at my house now
let's think about this just for a moment
because this is becoming a much bigger
story than any particular classified
document although we will get to the
aspect of the story that relates to
classification that's a separate story
it's a relevant one but it's a separate
story think for a moment the same
Republicans who were furiously
apoplectically up in arms about the
supposed mishandling of classified
documents at Joe Biden's private office
and residence are now conveniently
silent about the discovery of classified
documents at the home of another one of
their own because remember the same
thing happened with Donald Trump with
hundreds of documents which he tried to
keep and wanted at his house
orders of magnitude difference between
these stories but you one could argue
you put the Trump's situation aside that
the Biden and Pence situations are much
more analogous or similar I want to
remind you of some things that former
vice president Mike Pence previously
said here is an interview that Mike
Pence gave to ABC News back in November
and this exact topic came up you take
any classified documents with you from
the White House
uh I I did not no
do you see any reason for anyone to take
classified documents with them leaving
the White House
well there'd be no reason to have
classified documents particularly if
they were in an unprotected area
right now is his answer technically
correct in that someone else took them
assistance took them whatever you know
we we start to get into this more
semantic discussion of what does it
really mean to take what does it really
mean to have what does it really mean to
relocate a document but of course the
spirit of this conversation
is that there are no such documents at
his house here's another uh example of
Mike Pence this was from uh earlier this
month in fact take a listen to this one
our staff reviewed all of the materials
in our office and wow in our residence
to ensure oh that there were no
classified
materials that that left the White House
or remained in our possession and I I
remain confident that that was done in a
thorough and careful way I guess it
wasn't right I guess I guess he was
wrong about that as well and has
completely lost control of what's going
on in his home I mean there were fun
house mirrors and you couldn't tell that
the documents were classified who the
hell knows but obviously not true let's
look at one more instance of this here
is Mike Pence in a previous interview
saying he doesn't want to diminish the
importance of protecting classified
documents and that everything was very
buttoned up every eye was crossed and T
dotted I know I know it's a it's a
Hannity thing um here is Mike Patrick
ever want to diminish uh the importance
of protecting classified documents in
the nation's secret there was a very
formal process during my time it was
super formal everybody wore tuxedos
while they did it at the White House to
see to that yeah no it all have oh by
the way he had documents at his house
despite claiming multiple times that he
didn't so my biggest ass my biggest
issue with this story is the astounding
hypocrisy that is that has come to light
and has become I mean unabashedly they
don't even blush when they present their
double standards and it goes to show
that the Republican party will play
politics with National Security
if we believe that they consider this
issue of classified documents to be a
matter of National Security they claim
it is at least when it's Joe Biden if we
believe that
and yet they still use these situations
to attack the opposing party but never
themselves
it means they are turning a blind eye to
the very national security issue that
they claim these National these uh
classified document situations represent
which means there is nothing they will
not play politics with and that's
absolutely the case now there's another
issue okay I read online people saying
well you at this point you should really
check every former president's house and
office and every former vice president's
house and office apparently because of
what's going on
I propose to you
that this is not limited to presidents
and vice presidents it would be a shock
to me if they were to search the offices
and Residences of cabinet members for
example
um maybe not Secretary of the Interior
but certainly like Secretary of State as
an example I would be shocked if there
weren't some classified documents at the
homes of others as well Democrats
Republicans notice I'm not mentioning
partisan politics here is it ridiculous
or is it to be expected I don't know you
know the truth is that elected officials
review thousands or tens of thousands of
files when they're in office things get
moved around things could get misfiled
misclassified misplaced whatever it's
not a defense by the way I believe every
one of these cases should be
investigated and I'll get to that in a
moment but when you are dealing with
this volume of documents and you're
dealing with human beings after all it's
not a huge shock what it shouldn't be is
a partisan issue if it is determined
that files have been found
and it genuinely seems that it was an
accident in oversight whatever they
should be returned immediately law
enforcement should look into it and then
we have to move on and go beyond that
now as I said before the doj should
treat every one of these situations the
same in that they should investigate all
of them if and when the investigation
reveals that the facts of each situation
is different then you start dealing with
the situations differently and so if you
look at the Pence and Biden situations
which I do believe are quite similar and
you find this was not intentional these
documents were founded immediately
turned over etc etc and then you look at
the Trump situation and you're talking
about hundreds not a dozen documents
you're talking about people on video
moving them or moving these documents
around when Trump has already been asked
to return them you look at Trump using
lawyers to try not to return them and
then the lawyers lie and say we've
turned over everything we have have but
then it turns out they didn't that is a
different set of facts and so that would
change the scope and nature of the
investigation now Mitch McConnell was
asked about this and he sort of played
Coy take a look at what he said
records showing at the price uh Joe
Biden's home and now we're running
around what happened Mike Pence and what
specifically should Congress do to
prevents
well if recorder has a justice
department handles it I think they ought
to treat everybody the same who has
misplaced
uh classified documents now that is an
interesting statement because it does
appear that Joe Biden misplaced
documents
from what we know
at this point it seems as though Mike
Pence misplaced documents but Trump
stole documents Trump gathered up had
gathered up hundreds of documents and
had him sent to his house that's very
different than a dozen documents were
left over and they were found then
immediately returned so in a sense you
know the spirit of what Mitch McConnell
is saying sure yeah I mean treat all
these things the same and that they
should all be investigated but misplaced
is a mischaracterization of much of what
we believe took place here now there I
want to bring up a separate but valid
issue is there over classification of
documents in the United States you know
I'm not going to be able to answer this
question for you in order to really
answer this question accurately one
needs to have access to documents I
simply don't have access to and one
needs to have uh insight into the exact
process for classification that I
certainly don't have but we've talked
about over criminalization in society
as a problem and separately there are
people who have access to this apparatus
of classification who say that in the
United States we habitually over
classify documents and that arguably
some of these documents could be the
Biden documents the Pence documents the
Trump documents whatever some of these
documents maybe really shouldn't even
have been classified in the first place
a difficult question for me or many of
you in the audience to answer but
certainly a valid question that Canon
should be asked Fox News propagandist
Tucker Carlson
is proposing a different explanation to
the Mike Pence classified document
situation and Tucker Carlson's Theory
really a hypothesis but sometimes we say
Theory colloquially is that Mike Pence
just happened to find these documents at
his house right now because Pence is in
cahoots with the justice department
under Merrick Garland's leadership to
take attention away from what Joe Biden
did and to try to screw Donald Trump we
are really learning a lot about
propaganda this week from Tucker Carlson
you might remember on yesterday's show
we had a segment about the floating
space vagina you and I would call it a
cloud because that's what it was but
Tucker Carlson found it extraordinarily
disturbing that was an instructive view
into right-wing fear-mongering today
it's conspiracy theories here's what
Tucker Carlson had to say he said that a
few times
then just days ago Mike Pence sent his
personal attorney to search his family's
home in Carmel Indiana for classified
documents
now if Mike Pence didn't think he had
classified documents why would he send
his lawyer to go look for classified
documents hmm we can't say for certain
but it's entirely possible in fact it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do
this by federal prosecutors who are
trying to build a case against his old
boss Donald whoa now the point would be
to show that not every federal official
walks off with State Secrets Donald
Trump was uniquely evil in that regard
as in so many others and again he's
minimizing the fact that the Trump
situation is so dramatically different
than the Biden or Pence situations
stole versus misplaced refused to give
back versus immediately turned over used
lawyers to prevent returning the
documents versus used lawyers to
immediately return the documents but
Tucker doesn't want you to think about
any of those differences Mike Pence
didn't do it
so if that was the plan and we suspect
that it was right it backfired
spectacularly because Mike Pence's
lawyer promptly discovered classified
documents uh-oh he immediately loaded
these documents into his car and drove
them back to Washington to hand them
over to authorities Mike Pence mean yeah
so you know one of the things about most
of these conspiracy theories is that
they are either unfalsifiable or
unlikely to ever be proven or disproven
and that fact becomes part of the
conspiracy theory let me explain what I
mean by that Tucker Carlson says you
know what this could have been
this could have been the justice
department
uh recruiting Mike Pence in order to
help build a stronger case against Trump
so they said go have your lawyer look
for documents your lawyer certainly
won't find any and then our case that
what Trump did is uniquely bad will be a
stronger case now of course there is no
evidence whatsoever of that and it is
unlikely that there is ever going to be
evidence of that the most reasonable
explanation for why there won't be
evidence of that is because Tucker
Carlson made it up but the way that
Tucker Carlson and his followers
interpret these types of unfalsifiable
conspiracy theories is that when there
is no confirmation one way or the other
because again there's no evidence it's
sort of like if you said to me David can
you give me proof that you don't own a
Lexus
and I would say to you well it's hard to
prove a negative but I mean I can show
you the car I do have and I can show you
the insurance for the car I have and
you'll see it's not a Lexus and then you
could go well it's not really proof you
don't have a Lexus you also might have
registered it under someone else or you
might have it stored in a different
garage how can I prove a negative and
for a lot of these conspiracy theories
the way it will go is remember Tucker
proposed that thing that the justice
department was working with Pence and he
never really was able to disprove it
well right but no proof was found that
that was going on yeah but it's very
suspicious that they weren't able to
clear themselves of that well but how do
you prove a negative it's the exact same
mechanism the other uh and this is
common conspiracy theories are often
based on at least some premises that
can't be disproven and and what that
leads to is whether or not the theory is
true the people who follow have no way
to verify its authenticity and that
becomes part of the problem so another
clinic from Tucker Carlson on how this
stuff works and remember his audience is
uniquely suited to be targeted by this
type of stuff and when it comes to in
court
Fox News lawyers are quick to remind uh
um uh courts that Tucker Carlson is not
a news person
he's doing entertainment using Hyperbole
and nothing he says should be taken as
literally the truth because he's not
doing news but he does a segment like
this and all of a sudden a huge portion
of his followers believe well that
sounds right it sounds like this was
Pence and Cahoots with the justice
department there is no such evidence
we'll take take a quick break we'll be
back after this with just a packed
program today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
well there are seven dead in another
mass shooting this one in California now
what's confusing and I admit it's it is
confusing this is not the mass shooting
from a few days ago this is a different
California mass shooting and uh BBC News
has a brief article about it Half Moon
Bay seven dead in another California
mass shooting the U.S state of
California is reeling from its third
mass shooting in eight days after a man
shot dead seven former co-workers South
of San Francisco this was in Half Moon
Bay some of the victims were
chinese-american the suspect Chun Li
Zhao 66 years old was arrested after
driving to a police station this is
remember separate from the death of 11
people in Monterey Park which is six
hours southeast of Half Moon Bay and
just over a week ago six people
including a teenage mother and baby were
killed at a property in Goshen in
central California now the there have
been 40 mass shootings in the United
States this year so far let me make sure
I'm being clear about that mass
shootings if you want to know how many
shootings have there been it's hundreds
hundreds hundreds but if we limit it to
mass shootings there have been 40. this
year and it is of course the 25th of
January so more than one per day you can
find information about them on the gun
violence archive they have a category
called mass shootings they also have a
separate category for all shootings
which you can find and uh you will see
um the shooting I just mentioned listed
Half Moon Bay since this incident
yesterday there were two more mass
shootings including uh not including the
two those two shootings were in Oakland
California one killed four injured and
in Red Springs North Carolina three
killed and one injured also listed here
from a few days ago is the Monterey Park
shooting 12 dead 9 injured we're out of
idea is guys we don't know how to
prevent this of course this is the only
country where this happens with this
regularity but we have absolutely no
idea how to prevent it we're all out of
ideas even though we haven't really
tried anything yet and I think this is
as good a time as any
two remind everyone's memory uh refresh
everyone's memory of the list I provided
who knows after which mass shooting
maybe this was after a Texas mass
shooting a year ago it's constant so I
don't know when I last showed you this
list it's probably been about a year we
have things that we can do and what I
would immediately do if things were up
to me and again remember this is all
without
displacing the second amendment that we
have a second amendment none of my
suggestions here say get rid of the
Second Amendment but here are things we
could immediately do end the Gun Show
loophole which refers to the fact that
federal law doesn't require unlicensed
private sellers to do a background check
if you just privately sell a gun and
someone shows up to get it you are not
required as an unlicensed private seller
to have a background check done on that
individual that's a horrifying loophole
we should have Universal background
checks which would require just about
every Firearms transaction
to go through the nics national instant
criminal background check system and
that would close what is sometimes
called the private sale exemption
Universal background checks are not
required by federal law there are 22
States in DC which do require them at
least for some private sales but is not
nearly Universal there should be a
mandatory waiting period from when you
purchase the gun to when you actually
get the gun there should be no high
capacity weapons sold to anybody under
age 25 you should be required to have
gun insurance and it should be
significantly more expensive without a
parent if you were under 25 if you're
under 25 and you want a gun you should
be required to get Community Support
letters from adults in your community
that can say I know this person and I
have no concerns about them having a
firearm some weapons should be banned I
mean there there are some weapons that
they're they're of no recreational or
other value than as mass killing
machines they aren't uh valuable as in
terms of sport or hunting I'm not
pretending I have the full list right
now but there should be some weapons
banned you should be required to have a
periodic mental health evaluation and
the licensing process itself to even get
the license to get the gun in the first
place should be significantly more
extensive there should be a written and
practical test like for a driver's
license there should be a training and
Licensing period that isn't just one
weekend it should be longer like with
vehicles and we should also have a gun
buyback program give people an off-ramp
that feels better then we're going to be
confiscating guns now I know every time
I present this list someone writes and
says David that wouldn't have stopped
this specific shooter or that specific
shooter well but it might stop the next
one
and it would have stopped some of them
if we think of each shooting that has
taken place in almost every case some of
these items would have been relevant
some of these items not all
and it would still be a worthy cause to
reduce the number of mass shootings it's
January 5th and we've had 40 mass
shootings in the United States so that
is a list that every time I look at it
continues to make a lot of sense some of
these items there actually is
significant National support for some of
them there is not necessarily
um but we have things we can try
and so far the things that have been
done uh other than that period when
there was an assault weapons ban in the
90s and there was a reduction in mass
shootings during that period of time
nothing else seems to uh prayers aren't
helping fixing doors isn't helping
um triple pane windows are not helping
right I mean the things that the right
talks about aren't helping and then
lastly the right says oh Mental Health
they also don't want to fund
um making the mental health support
system in this country more robust so
they're also Hypocrites as far as that
goes hey does cancel culture actually
exist in light of the latest right wing
cancellation of the new M Ms we have to
talk about cancel culture does cancel
culture actually exist someone sent me
an article from the center on a
stateless society uh which is sort of
the the basis for this segment and that
article really got me thinking and what
I mean by does cancel culture really
exist is sometimes things are canceled
in the sense that people are fired or a
Show is canceled or someone is
ostracized or people change their views
or activists Express opinions that say I
don't like what you said that happens
right that takes place but does the
cancel culture that Republicans describe
actually exist Does this culture exist
when Republicans scream we are being
canceled by the woke left I believe that
it does not really exist often what is
happening is that someone's words or
actions are having consequences as those
words and actions are being evaluated in
the free market of ideas which
Republicans claim to support oftentimes
the canceled still have a bully pulpit
plenty of access to corporate media
social media and other platforms to
spread their views sometimes they're
quote canceled in the sense that they
lose when they're entertainers they lose
one opportunity but then they come back
and they get another opportunity and
sometimes it takes a little while you
look at Mel Gibson who had this horrible
incident where he was pulled over drunk
driving and he said to the officer are
you a Jew and I I guess the officer was
Jewish you know what are the odds
um and then he you know made all sorts
of other horrible statements and there
was a period during which Mel Gibson
wasn't doing much work in Hollywood but
like then he's back then he started
getting work again and so is that is
that really a cancellation there was a
period during which his statements and
actions impacted his career it seems
logical that in such a free market there
are consequences to the things that you
say and that you do
and so often and this is really what I
believe is at the Crux of this meme of
cancel culture that the right likes to
talk about often those who are accused
of doing the canceling are people from
groups that only more recently are
getting a louder voice they are from
previously marginalized groups and
thanks to social media and the internet
some of those individuals some of those
groups are now having more of a voice to
express their views people speak out and
they push back against marginalization
and sometimes there are consequences to
the person doing the marginalizing and
now they have been canceled as if it's
bad that there are consequences for the
things that they have said or done now
it's also worth noting that by their own
definition
of canceling it is often Republicans
that are doing the canceling despite the
fact that they say it's the left that
does the canceling and we see this in
the way that they try to silence
descending voices in the media and in
Academia and in politics they want to
control the narrative they want to shut
down voices that challenge their
ideology and when they get called out
they say it's cancer culture as a way to
deflect responsibility and to play the
victim everything they accuse the left
of the doing they do let me remind you
of something else this isn't as popular
in the last couple of years but you used
to often hear from the right
saying you're offended isn't an argument
and I agreed with them right if someone
makes a statement and someone on the
left or the right responds by saying
that's offensive
boom Conversation Over
I think that that is a way to shut down
an argument to shut down debate and it's
not actually an argument in and of
itself you've offended me boom well
let's let's talk about what I said let's
talk about why why okay
that's cancel culture
is exactly the same thing it is exactly
equivalent to I'm offended and the
conversation oh that's cancel culture
that's it no we're done it's exactly the
same thing now
let I'll be upfront with everybody here
you all know I am not blind to the
reality that sometimes people may go too
far in their activism sometimes the
calls for someone's head are premature
or they are inappropriate if we go back
and think about by the way when
Democrats demanded that their own
Senator Al Franken resign Al Franken
participated in a tasteless joke that
was photographed and it was tasteless
there's no question about it but in a
sense Democrats were too quick to say
you got to resign Al Franken partially
because Democrats wanted to show how how
fair and nonpartisan they were when it
came to these things and the reality is
that what Al Franken did was really
quite minor compared to the things
others have gotten away with so I'm not
blind to the fact that sometimes people
go too far but that doesn't mean you
can't hold anyone accountable and if you
do it's cancel culture so we need to
shift from calling people out to
uh it's so cliche like sometimes that
people say we need to call people in to
talk right this is all the reality of
there are now many more platforms on
which people can speak
and there are many more platforms on
which people can respond to speech and
so that's the reality and so the idea of
cancel culture is this monolithic
movement to silence people is basically
meaningless it's not accurately
representing what's happening there's no
conspiracy it's the marketplace of ideas
that the right holds up
as a place where ideas or jokes or
bigotry
or ad campaigns or content or whatever
are open to criticism and they're open
to consequences so let's get away from
the term cancel culture I use it
tongue-in-cheek when I say look it's
cancel culture from the right but it's
really a political Boogeyman and it's
meant to silence voices often
marginalize voices it's meant to protect
the status quo particularly when it
comes to Republicans by making them
immune to the consequences of their
actions and their words don't fall for
it let's actually push back against the
concept of cancel culture
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show there is
something super interesting going on in
South Carolina where failed former
president Donald Trump is really
struggling to find state lawmakers
willing to show up at this stupid rally
event he has planned for this weekend
and support him on stage now let me kind
of remind you what's going on uh Trump's
running for president again in 2024 he
announced relatively early he basically
hasn't left his house since the
announcement in November but now he is
starting events one such event is in
South Carolina this weekend our
correspondent Luke Beasley is going to
be there he will be interviewing people
should be pretty interesting content
that we will have for you as a result
now Trump doesn't seem to be struggling
to get Federal level lawmakers who
represent South Carolina to go and stand
with him at the rally
but the state lawmakers are hilariously
not super thrilled about participating
there is a rolling stone article so sad
Trump's South Carolina rally getting
little support from State lawmakers
despite making numerous pleading phone
calls the former president's team is
hitting a wall in the state writes Peter
Wade for Rolling Stone The Washington
Post reports that Trump's team has been
making pleading phone calls to potential
supporters across the state but many are
responding with less than enthusiasm
because South Carolina lawmakers are not
yet ready to commit to a candidate
especially when two of the state's
Republicans are eyeing presidential runs
themselves that's South Carolina former
South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley and
current South Carolina Senator Tim Scott
the article also mentions Lindsey Graham
and Henry McMaster are expected to show
up and show support
uh this is really really interesting
because if you look at polling in South
Carolina you find that the majority of
South Carolina's residents disapprove of
trump and to a certain degree it seems
as though the state politicians people
in the State House State Senate are
either on the same page in their
disapproval for Trump or are kind of
reading the tea leaves and saying well I
don't know that I want to get ahead of
myself and to support Trump and be
publicly seen and tied to Trump when
many of my constituents don't seem to be
big fans we don't even know if Trump
will be the nominee we don't know what
things will look like come next year and
so you end up with this situation where
only five of the state's Republican
senators and representatives are
publicly supporting Trump some uh like
Jeff Duncan are pushing back against his
policies and has have been critical of
Trump's trade policy for example or have
said Trump hasn't been doing the right
things to make the immigration system
more fair or whatever the case may be
and then some some State reps from South
Carolina have gone even further than
simply not voicing support you've got
for example like Nancy mace who is
trying to pass legislation that
undermines some of Trump's policy ideas
like she wants to protect so-called
dreamers from deportation whereas Trump
was open to deporting dreamers so this
is potentially going to be a problem for
Trump as this campaign tries to get
going there have been advisers to Trump
just blanketing South Carolina trying to
find people to come and support him and
the important thing to remember and we
learned this from the Democratic primary
just because a candidate can have a
rally with a few thousand people
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
are well-liked Statewide and you know
one of the things we experienced during
the Democratic primary was that if you
based your estimates of support for
Bernie Sanders based on Twitter and
Reddit and I was one of his supporters
you had a much inflated uh sense of
Bernie's support within the Democratic
party and then when voting actually
started taking place you got a very
different sense and we know ultimately
how that went down that all being said
the polls as we reviewed yesterday are
still looking pretty good for Trump in
the Republican primary there was a
period there in early December where Ron
DeSantis was really doing quite well in
the polling but it does appear at least
right now that Donald Trump has a
commanding lead in just about every
Republican primary poll of substance
that being said nobody else has
announced Trump is being put up in polls
against people who aren't even
officially running yet and that could
mean something quite different once we
get more announcements so we're going to
follow it I will not be covering the
rally this weekend I'm actually going to
be away
um but Luke Beasley is going to be there
and then we'll have clips for when I am
back we have to come terms with a
reality maybe it's a new reality I don't
know Donald Trump and Carrie Lake aren't
like Hitler okay that's not what I'm
saying but the growing fad of right-wing
rallies by people especially when they
aren't running for elected office to
fire people up with their authoritarian
rhetoric and right-wing populist
rhetoric are in the style of the rallies
that used to be done by Mussolini and
Hitler and others not saying Trump is
Hitler not saying Kerry lake is
Mussolini okay but understanding the
history if you have an understanding of
the history you could come only to this
conclusion the latest example is that
Kerry Lake who lost her race to be
Arizona's Governor she's holding a rally
called a save Arizona rally presumably
to save Arizona from what I don't know
maybe Katie Hobbs the person that
actually was elected governor we will
learn more about it I guess on January
29th she tweeted get ready Kerry lake is
holding a rally on Sunday January 29th
you do not want to miss this hashtag
save Arizona if you look at the picture
they use uh it is
it's certainly trumpian uh it's uh
listen if you're if you're only
listening today
um check out Kerry Lake's Twitter and
look at the picture that was selected
um to promote this uh this event in
Arizona
um Carrie Lake lost
Kerry Lake isn't going to be governor uh
I mean if she runs in the future and
wins she could end up as Governor but
none no legal mechanism no maneuvering
no lawsuit none of what Carrie lake has
been raising money for is going to make
her the governor Katie Hobbs is the
governor this is an adject prop rally
and we really have to understand the
history these rallies are very
reminiscent of the fascist rallies that
people like Mussolini and Hitler would
do Mussolini and Hitler would routinely
hold rallies to show their Authority
to get people behind their cause as
misguided as it might have been the
rallies would often include shouting and
chanting and music similar to Modern
Republican rallies the fascist rallies
would include rhetoric that was meant to
make people afraid and make people hate
certain groups of people Trump and Lake
have been doing this regularly uh you've
got to be afraid of Democrats you've got
to be afraid of marxists you've got to
be afraid of immigrants you've got to be
afraid of academics you've got to be on
media Elites you've got to be afraid of
all of them they're going to come for
your kids you've got to be afraid of
drag queens and trans people and all of
this stuff and Mussolini specifically
would use rallies to vilify opponents as
well that's a trump Carey Lake Classic
our political Rivals must be vilified
Hillary's bad Adam Schiff has a
watermelon head and Joe Biden's a
dangerous Marxist and Hunter Biden and
Barack Obama and all the different
people Obama
um the fascist rallies also have a
tradition of using
language and symbols that are crafted to
manipulate followers
um Hitler was well known for using
dramatic emotive language and grandiose
gestures during his speeches and symbols
there were Nazi symbols all over to
boost morale
Mussolini had this phrase believe obey
fight in his speeches and it's become a
slogan of Italian Fascism and Trump has
this routine he does where you see what
he does we will make America strong
again and we will make America you know
and it kind of just builds and builds
and builds from there there is a big
similarity music was a part of these
fascist and Nazi rallies and Trump has
started to do this thing where he will
lament the downfall of America over a
backdrop of sort of melodramatic music
the similarities are stunning and we're
not saying Trump is Hitler we're not
saying care every lake is Mussolini or
you know whoever but it's important to
understand
prior movements that have used this type
of imagery that have used these types of
events we we don't have anyone going to
the Arizona rally
if someone wanted to be our
correspondent and do some interviews it
would be interesting sociologically and
culturally and psychologically to see
who the hell goes to these rallies
anyway
um but you can get it get in touch info
davidpackman.com if you're like set up
to record interviews and want to want to
go to the event on January 29th we will
be at Trump South Carolina rally Luke
Beasley will be there and then when I
get back from my trip I will have those
clips for you so a lot of wild wacky and
dangerous stuff going on and maybe there
maybe there's one other thing that I
think is worth saying about this
I didn't use the word cult once in this
particular segment
we can't ignore that storyline either
and on the one hand you have
how reminiscent the Trump Lake type
rallies are of fascist and authoritarian
rallies yes you have that
at the follower level we also have the
cult analysis which is that much of the
when you interview these folks as we
have done many times
the thinking the statements the speech
the rationalization the uh all of it
that we see is very reminiscent of
someone that has been brainwashed into a
cult and to a great degree we've spoken
to experts on Cults and psychologists
and experts on authoritarianism and all
all these different things to a great
degree you have at the top this
authoritarian fascist rally style and
mode of messaging and Below what are
essentially cult members as the
followers and that is a dangerous and
disturbing combination make sure you're
subscribed to the David packman show on
YouTube it's easy it's free I will
update you tomorrow on the aftermath of
the YouTube Fiasco that I told you about
but as of last check let me see here
we have somehow these are unbelievable
numbers added hold on let me see here on
Monday we added 12 000 YouTube
subscribers and yesterday Tuesday we
added about six that's 18
000 new subscribers over the last two
days stunning all from that one clip so
I'll have a full report to you about
that tomorrow but remember you can
subscribe free at youtube.com slash the
davidpackman show
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well the next layer in the American
laughing stock of Republicans
controlling the House of Representatives
is happening now not only are
Republicans blocking Democrats Adam
Schiff and Eric swalwell from the house
intelligence panel they have placed
Marjorie Taylor green and Trump's
lunatic doctor Ronnie Jackson on the
coronavirus committee I know I know it
is an absolute pathetic joke now on the
bonus show later today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad exactly we are going
to talk about the first part of what I
just told you Kevin McCarthy blocking
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell from the
house Intel panel NBC news reports
speaker Kevin McCarthy followed through
on his threat to prevent the two
Democratic lawmakers from keeping their
seats on the intelligence committee
so that's happening let me mention a
different aspect to this which is closer
to the bottom of this article meanwhile
McCarthy named congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene who had been suspended
from social media platforms for
promoting covet disinformation to the
select panel on the coronavirus pandemic
Congressman Ronnie Jackson of Texas a
republican who was Trump's White House
physician also got the nod for the covid
panel Jeffries will now have an
opportunity to appoint Democratic
members to the special panels they also
by the way before we start weighing in
further on this there's also a
weaponization panel what are they
studying themselves no
Republicans have said the new
weaponization panel will examine
Republican accusations that the justice
department FBI and other law enforcement
are being weaponized to investigate
conservatives including Trump they're
going to look at the FBI search of
Mar-A-Lago and other things okay
um listen
we knew they were going to do this we
knew that they were going to flip
everything on its head up was going to
be down left was going to be right they
were going to investigate Hunter Biden
rather than anybody actually connected
to government today we knew that they
were going to do all of these different
things and look at the reactions from
these folks Ronnie Jackson this is maybe
one of the most dishonest prominent
doctors I mean I can think of some
others actually but Ronnie Jackson's the
guy who has Trump's doctor said Trump
was six feet three inches tall and
weighed 239 pounds listen I'm not about
fat shaming I'm not about whatever I'm
against lying and there is no way in
hell Trump is 6'3 and weighs 239 but
Ronnie Jackson kept up the LIE Ronnie
Jackson tweeting and gleefully
responding to this committee assignment
saying quote I'm proud to announce that
I've been chosen for the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
Every Lie told To Us by fauci will be
revealed every lie about the vaccine
will be revealed every lie that was used
to lock you down will be Unearthed we
will reveal the truth
by the way does anybody remember being
locked down I remember when I had to get
takeout for a couple weeks and then sit
outside at restaurants but I have to
tell you I don't remember any lockdowns
Ronnie Jackson going on in a separate
tweet to say be ready fauci the American
people are about to find out everything
you did to this country during covid uh
I think Dr fauci would be glad for the
country to learn about all the things he
did during covid Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeting I am honored to serve on the
select subcommittee on the coronavirus
pandemic it's time to reveal the truth
on the origins of kovid
wow I didn't know she knew anything
about that the authoritarian Democrat
response vaccines and fauci's
n-i-a-i-d involvement in gain of
function research
we are a joke folks we are a joke the
world sees this and wonders what the
hell is wrong with these people remember
this moment where Marjorie Taylor green
was asked by a reporter about how
children died of covid people who
weren't obese died of covid and Marjorie
Taylor green laughed dangerous do you
feel any responsibility for keeping
people in Georgia say you know there are
children skinny people who have died of
the coronavirus do you feel any
responsibility to crack me up
um you know what I think people's
responsibility is their own yeah so she
now will be examining and investigating
what happened during the coronavirus
pandemic it is absolutely Bonkers and
you know this is going to be endless
grandstanding now one thing I want to
ask ask you about is
when they have these coveted hearings
right
it's something we could cover live but
would my coverage of it legitimize or
legitimate to use a less common version
of the term would my coverage in a sense
legitimize hearings that are completely
unserious in every way
the entertainment value might be high
but these really are people who should
be relegated to you know irrelevant jobs
not anything serious so is it the type
of thing that we should cover live or
not let me know leave a comment and I'm
curious to know your thoughts despite
the American right wing claiming that
the left is indoctrinating children
through critical race Theory and
left-wing university courses it is
actually the right wing that is
indoctrinating children now we have this
recent example from Florida where Ron
DeSantis and the Florida Board of
Education banned and an advanced
placement every time I see AP I think
Associated Press banned an advanced
placement black history course because
they claim that it contains queer Theory
and indoctrination and things that
should not be in such a course now
yesterday I talked to you about how
absurd this is and the fact that this is
not a required course this is actually
it's not even elective it's an elective
advanced placement course and if you
think about it as a college equivalent
college courses regularly have more
Niche topics of interest to the people
that want to take the course you don't
have to take it anyway it was all absurd
but this is an example of the right
claiming we are working very hard to
stop the left from indoctrinating our
kids but the reality is that the
propaganda of child indoctrination is
overwhelmingly from the right here is
the latest propaganda being promoted by
Mike Huckabee this was this came on
during a commercial break on Fox
Business it is promoting the kids guide
to fighting socialism which you can get
at socialism stinks.com we've spoken
before about the president Trump kids
guide from it looks like the same
organization because Huckabee promotes
it and like the font looks the same this
is the free kids guide to president
Trump which will allow children to learn
about President Trump's accomplishments
in office president Trump's vision for
America and how president Trump's
policies are right for America this is
straight up for kids okay this is not
the type of thing I want to teach kids
which is here's how you think for
yourself
here's how you can determine whether you
are reading something that is true or
false that's what I want to teach kids
okay that's not what the Trump kids
guide for children teaches them in 2017
the Trump Administration proposed
cutting funding for after-school
programs that provided a safe and
positive environment for children and
instead they redirected that money to
religious organizations and groups that
promote conservative value that is the
right funding the rights indoctrination
of children but they say it's the left
that doesn't
in Texas the State Board of Education
has promoted a conservative agenda in
state schools They promoted the teaching
of creationism the downplaying of the
role of slavery in the Civil War to
children that is right-wing
indoctrination of kids in Arizona the
State Board of Education approved a
curriculum that promotes a conservative
pro-trump agenda and it downplays the
contributions of minorities and
marginalized groups in American history
in Idaho a school board member promoted
the teaching of Bible courses in public
school and said we should be teaching
creationism alongside evolution in West
Virginia the State's Department of
Education promoted a conservative agenda
in public schools including promoting
coal mining and downplaying the role of
climate change in their educational
standards I'll give you one more example
in Oklahoma
State Board of Education promoted a
conservative agenda and approved
textbooks that present a conservative
perspective on American history and on
government they say the left
indoctrinates children they are actually
the ones that do it so
what is it that we can do
all the things we talk about right
you've got to be involved with school
boards you've got to be involved with
education issues at the local state and
federal level and we have to fight
against the idea that teaching kids
critical thinking is liberal
indoctrination and this is something
that is unfortunately becoming
widespread when you talk to
conservatives many not all when you talk
to some conservatives and say we should
really be teaching critical thinking
when kids are 10 11 12. we should be
teaching media literacy we should be
doing all these things many of these
right-wingers say that's liberal
indoctrination but of course it's not
the the reality though is that if more
kids knew how to think for themselves if
more kids knew how to think critically
if more kids knew how to
um suss out whether messages they are
being given in the media are true or
false or are trying to convince them of
something that isn't true
it is true that it would hurt the
conservative movement Fox News relies on
having an uninformed audience where they
turn on the TV and Tucker Carlson says
see this floating space vagina which is
just a cloud you should be scared of
that and then the audience goes yeah I
should whereas an audience that is more
media literate and that is more
well-versed in critical thinking
wouldn't fall for that so I've mentioned
this before we are very very close to
publishing a kids book on critical
thinking this is going to be quite
literally an illustrated children's book
I've been saying for years and years and
years there need to be better materials
and more materials for teaching kids
this stuff early we are doing it uh we
are almost done with the uh text of the
book we are trying to get the
illustrations finalized and set up the
printing of the book Etc we are sort of
putting our money where our mouth is and
we are going to be publishing such a
book it's going to be fantastic a couple
people already reached out and said
David when you do this I'm buying 100
copies and I'm gonna send send them I'm
going to bring them to libraries in my
area this is super super exciting and
I'm glad to be doing it and I'll have
more information for you about it very
very soon we have a voicemail number
that number is
2192 David P thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave Pacman but you
can call Dave packman at 2192 David P
here is a caller who learning that I
will soon be in Florida
is asking whether this is the trip
during which I will eat fast food with
Farren cousins listen to this
hi David
um on the bonus show on Monday yes
um you mentioned going to Florida for a
trip I just want to remind you if you
happen to see Fair event I just want to
remind you that like a year ago you said
he would uh
I think he said he would get you
McDonald's Burger King
I think it was just a fast food Burger
basically but I remember the night he
tweeted at you so I just want you to
recall that
um YouTube would be good hosts if
there's ever some sort of progressive
equivalent
to
you know see Patrick or something but
yeah I would love to co-host something
with farron so listen uh I am going to
be in Florida but I am not going to see
Farren on this trip I'm going to be in a
different part of Florida doing some
appearances including on the Patrick
David show and with Anthony pompliano of
course all assuming it doesn't get
canceled as I told you Lex Friedman
canceled our appearance together last
week a very very last minute I I'm
hopeful that next week's appearance is
in Florida
don't get canceled my goal is not to
have any fast food while I'm in Florida
I am looking forward to the restaurants
great food scene in the Miami area so I
am looking forward to that many
Argentinian restaurants I'm going to be
going to Argentinian restaurants getting
some empanadas getting a little milanesa
it's all happening but I hope not to
have any McDonald's or Burger King or
anything like that is it conceivable
some kind of emergency could take place
and I end up having no choice but to get
a Double Whopper it's possible it's
possible but let's hope it doesn't
happen on today's bonus show Kevin
McCarthy blocking swalwell and Schiff
from the Intel committee we will talk
about it when I'm joined by producer Pat
journalist deaths jumped 50 in 2022 led
by Ukraine and Mexico and Netflix is
finally they're really doing it this
time they're going to crack down on
password sharing and we will talk about
how and why and is it fair and all these
different things get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
sizable discount and it will be maybe
the best bonus show we've ever had oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad that's right
money will be
on today's bonus show and I hope Alex I
really hope it is not money that that I
ever end up having to pay someone in a
defamation settlement let's hope that
that's the case we'll see you then
foreign